a tory secret plan a plan that puts the
prosperity of working families at risk
cuts to tax credits cuts to child
benefit a threat to your family finances
seven and a half million families losing
an average of seven hundred and sixty
pounds a year working families can't
afford another five years of David
Cameron and this Tory government 75% of
the welfare spending the Tories would
want to cut his tax credits and char
benefit if you assume they just do the
same share of cuts in the next
parliament than in the last that means
over and above what George Osborne has
already announced because he's already
said he's going to freeze tax credits
he'll have to go further and do a 3.4
billion pound cut to tax credits and to
char benefits